[Music]
and follow the signs muse just sign
right here see submit it by holes with
genes mm-hmm people are trying to
discuss dating red flats you shouldn't
ignore oh I wish I knew this list like
what what's one for you if they have I
wish I knew this list don't get with I
wish no I seriously wish I knew this
list because I just don't know that's
I'm sorry which I wish I knew this list
cuz i frickin chose so many bad dates
well with me is if they if we have to
check in with each other all the [ __ ]
time but what if they're like you know
are you okay because I haven't heard
from you and I was worried that your
[ __ ] hate that that's what when
you're young you're so horny that you
don't care
yeah there's warning signs right there
but you go I don't care only through it
yeah so this was this discussion was
sparked by this tweet by hashtag roundup
where they asked people to share their
dating red flags you should not ignore
so here's some that we have in this
article here so the number one it says
when they're rude to the server at a
restaurant yeah that's a good one agreed
yup I don't like that when they're rude
to their mom for sure oh yeah that's a
big lots how they're gonna treat you
yeah that's exactly so another one is
they can't stop talking about themselves
narcissist
yeah well let's have a lot to see if
they had a lot of accomplishments I
would like to listen to them all day
they have an interesting life yeah like
oh this is that kid Alex Honnold talk
about scaling a mountain all day but if
you were dating him
and you were like [ __ ] don't you want
to know about me oh hey um can we stop
talking about the mountain and ask me
about how my day was yeah alright if
you're dating are transgender
transgender person they have two stories
to tell oh yeah so let's double the
amount of story time yeah true but I
guess if they bring it back to you
sometimes like how do you say like
that's not a one kind of thing if their
life was more interesting than mine I
would like to just listen forever
imagine dating someone they'd never
[ __ ] ask you what you like wait where
how you are what you like to do no
because I have an audience
that's a lot that will set you up really
well for me it's that and also the
opposite where it's like they only want
to hear me talk and never say anything
about themselves that one but don't they
stay mysterious have a take don't suck
have a take that's my [ __ ] right like
don't be so ambivalent that you're not
gonna take a position on something you
know who they are you don't know who
they are after that I'm like just tell
me what you think don't wait for me so
you can't do it like oh yeah I see that
well you're kind of like just in the
middle on you like oh this is cold but
this is cool too are you that yeah
you're almost scared to [ __ ] it up or
something and then you end up just being
so boring that it's like I'm good I
thought these are signs everywhere you
know I have a question for the latest so
like you know when I think most boys
they're they're young they're just so
horny they're like they're just thankful
that they can actually like go on a day
and then be with a girl and do all kinds
of stuff and then like they're blinded
right they don't even think about if
they're if they need to be vetted
they're just one they want acceptance so
from a girl's point of view since you're
doing like the picking right
what is the motivating factor for that
is that like loving commitment or like
because guys are very short-sighted like
in the very early stages of dating and
stuff we're just like can I kiss her
can I touch her you know oh yeah you
don't mean like it's it's like what
goals and and future plans they might
have just a kind of like when you're
thinking of like can I be with this man
for like five years I think if they're
funny and if they are like loving and
loyal cuz that's important to me bonny
loving you more it's so simple what is
funny what a funny loving a loyal with
anger problems the court I can't just
talk about himself no because to me it's
like you have to be able to like talk
about your feelings and express how you
feel because I'm not your mom I'm not
your therapist
I'm not your punching bag like you need
to come prepared for all this but what
if you both are still young right
the true ages well for me then if I'm
young then I'm looking at his friends do
you want to hang out with this group
like this I mean your group is that it's
a good indicator of who you are the
girls think so long-term we do it
Metis friends like what do you judge him
on then that's the goals like if we're
young like are you trying go to college
like what are you trying to like are you
trying to get a job and I think you're
still thinking very maturely cuz think
in high school yeah and then they say
this and then they they say this but
then the guy that drives them crazy is
the bad boy that they shouldn't be with
and they get with that one
but then what scares me is the dudes who
are like good guys finish last
you're the worst I'm a nice guy we'll
never win it's like Allah Jesus they're
the worst
rate this is what you are just coming
from a different angle brother we all
know everyone's trying to get laid but
you are a fraud you're playing the
sympathy cards you're not trying and
nobody wants to [ __ ] that guy right now
nobody wants to [ __ ] that guy and then
they're mad at the guys that are just
honest and they want to [ __ ] yes
I have friends like that they were so
[ __ ] weird but when you're like
twenty-one twenty-two like when girls
are twenty-one twenty-two and you're
like honest and you're like you know
what I'm just trying to smash if she's
like into it should be like all right
[ __ ] like I find you attractive you
find me attractive
you know you can't say that when you're
sixteen though no I'm not 16 you're
trying to attach love yeah out of any
when you're 16 you're still going after
your parents values or whatever values
you grew up with because you don't
really have your own you don't know [ __ ]
next one I wanted to only go after that
blonde hair looks into the distance like
she's sitting on a [ __ ] dock drinking
whiskey
after a long life I never looked at
anything I just accepted what you could
yeah I anybody were also pregnant and a
mom showed up with a knife in the hand
and bloody blood everywhere just like
he's a nice little T the signs know if
I'm not attention like I was so deprived
of love that if I got any sort of
attention I would gravitate to that
person oh wow does he love you oh you
like em love did that really date the
person that you dated you actually just
got with every time every time yeah I I
never dated ever even when I was trying
to date Casey it just it got serious
really fast I could I've never learned I
never got to experience that well dating
the world so you guys are talking about
this up for you I don't really need
and like but like you're considering
things about that person I never did
that
you me home run home on tears I want to
yeah that's right I was just like yeah
yeah you were gone next one they only
hit you up after midnight
oh yeah that's a booty call yeah what if
their jet like what if they're two
different times on what did they have
not anymore but their jet valid me yeah
next one they don't understand sarcasm
oh I hate that that just means they're
stupid us but low IQ [ __ ] yeah shallow
yeah like what do you mean my my oh no
what do you mean gonna be a long dinner
oh yeah oh man yeah I can't even make
friends with dudes if they don't
understand something oh yeah you're just
like this guy's a dumb [ __ ] yeah
if I feel like I could run circles
around people just like mentally I feel
like I can't respect them as a human
being yeah it's difficult you guys are
also in comedy though so it's huge for
you right maybe just in general like to
be able to understand an idea and see
like and kind of like feel the subtext
of the conversation like if I was like I
get like the conversation that Steve had
with this wife and I'm like and that
baby's cute as [ __ ] should we go rob it
if the person's like oh no I would never
like yeah crazy I'm sure somebody's out
there like you know how people actually
have their kids abducted on my life give
a [ __ ] about them I'm talking about a
stupid hypothetical we're talking about
Yard House you don't everyone who got
kidnapped in the world oh my god oh
that's another one two people that can't
even venture into hypotheticals because
they're too afraid of exploring that
thought that I can't stand like that is
something dangerous to me yeah or people
who can't leave I get it ya know
critical thinking that's scary
yes yeah like they can't even like
entertain a thought because already that
is already sinful in their head to even
go there I made up my sorry I'm just
like ooh what kind of small little world
do you live in or a scared little world
and I'm like dad that's gonna be kind of
weird for me
I hate stubborn people too but if they
look good I could make
you know there's a lot of things that
can like guys can have all the rules I
got and then they could see that one
girl and it goes I don't give a [ __ ] our
percent yeah no sarcasm I don't care but
the older you get though you start to
wise up good you're like yeah it's not
gonna work but then how do you have like
50 year olds dating 19 year olds because
they look good and they had why yeah and
then 19 year olds are like exactly well
a lot of them are also emotionally
stunted amen yeah these these rich guys
also like you know you have to think to
like these guys they dedicate like a
hundred hours a week to just work with
no social life so they get stuck at
whatever age they started working hard
at so if they if they did this at like
18 years old or whatever I think that
they're socially stunted and emotionally
stunted yeah that's really so they're
going for girls at the same mental
wavelength even though they're like old
guys but also they like like the way
they look too and they can't resist that
because it's like a drug guys looking at
women is like a drug for sure yeah like
it just feels like girls really don't
know the power that they have over just
looking good like they could look good
and want me now no no we are so [ __ ]
stupid that you could look kind of
wrecked one day but then you put makeup
on the next day and we're like wow she's
[ __ ] hot and then the next day you
look kind of wrecked again and we're
like wait is she hot and then the next
day you put on makeup again or like oh
yeah she's hot really you have no idea
there's also no the amount of power yeah
yeah you don't know what do what that
does to us you can't even believe well
yeah we even boobs it's like wow she has
really big boobs today oh wait no she
doesn't have big boobs the next day and
then like wait she's a big boobs
actually any weight I don't think she
has big boobs any like she has big boobs
oh my god I'm tired not even kidding
this is exactly the male model that's
how it does that's a KC's not any like
the guys are like dogs it's really like
it looks like you pull out a boner like
oh cool
like that in the bone you put in the
ground like oh the bone is done okay
it's crane Elvis yeah a better analogy
yeah I mean like and especially like
when you're young and you're just
starting to feel these like horny
hormones and [ __ ] there'll be times when
you look at a hot girl and she just
doesn't leave your mind and she becomes
like this centre of obsession you got I
got to see her again
I just have to see her dude like just
seeing her makes my day so bad so much
better we're talking about this I
understood people love people faked sick
to to get out of school I used to think
that I wasn't sick to go to school to
see the chick that I like because it
gave me [ __ ] feelings you say it's
cute but it's also kind of gross to draw
because it's like I I'm so horny for her
to like mixed emotions though you know
like feelings are weird because at the
end of the day what is it for its to
make you mate and have babies right so
it's all like yeah but that's what it's
like now with Nikki is like when I am
hugging her like that'd be this - and
goodbye it's like it's like I'm
constantly breathing in like it feels
like it's like it comes to taking a deep
breath yeah every bit of bulbs when you
matures what I feel like so for example
like I think girls they have one eight
with when females have sex they do it
lovingly and connecting leap right we're
guys I think they have to evolve to that
level it's just like jacking off or like
self pleasure even when they have sex
there's there's just it's just releasing
horniness right it's like a self
pleasure kind of thing but then once
they feel the feeling of love and
connection that is the experience that
it's like oh wow it took a lot all of
these for me to get to that level yeah
yeah and it's like when like an
ingenious case she's like make love to
me by slowly spitting in my mouth and
choking me
that's fast bit and I think that's
really beautiful with a loogie through
the nose but slowly I spit into my nose
like at Norman lerp it through my nose
and then spit it back out into your
mouth
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]